hey what's up guys it's Marcus brown
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hardware review video this one being of
the mattias USB 2.0 keyboard with a dock
obviously sent to me by Mattias now I've
actually receive this keyboard and did
an unboxing video that I uploaded about
two two and a half weeks ago
and so you can go ahead and check out
that unboxing I'll try to post this as a
video response to the unboxing of this
keyboard but that was just my first
impressions video this is going to be my
final impressions and basically overall
what I think is this keyboard also
according to their website and obviously
shown by this keyboard this keyboard
first of all is a very very nice solid
build keyboard it does have a number of
features that some people words don't
have but a number of standard features
that every keyboard should so first of
all it does have the white connects to
your computer is by USB so I'm just
going to move this here unfortunately it
does take two USB cables to plug into
your computer but that wasn't a really
big deal for me because it does have USB
hub and a dock so I'm just going to go
ahead and plug that in right here into
one of my USB hubs I have several at
this point so it doesn't really take
doesn't really imply really big deal to
me but it does plug into that way so
once I plugged them in I can pretty much
push it out the way and I can use the
keyboard full feature from here so the
driver is obviously plug and play I'm
going to zoom in a little bit here onto
this right-hand side of the keyboard
might not even focus that well but
here's a volume up volume down and mute
buttons which we're just fine with my
with Windows Vista laptop um the really
big feature of the selling point of this
this configuration is that it has a dock
up top as you can see this is the USB
2.0 dock so I'm going to zoom back out
again
so the USB 2.0 dock is basically it's
not a huge deal except for the fact that
is stay facing one of the hubs
and I say that because on the back there
is a USB 2.0 hub so there are three USB
ports out and one USB error to USB is
plugged into the computer on the side
you can obviously tell there's a height
adjustment right there so I can adjust
the height and pretty much have it as
high as tilt as I want the USB 2.0
keyboard is really long I don't really
need it to be this long so I kind of
tuck it under the desk there where no
one needs to see it but that's basically
a that's basically it for the the cord
so yeah otherwise it's a very nice you
know solid build keyboard has a number
pad on the right hand side all the
function keys and everything
not much too different about this
keyboard it fits nicely with my mouse
over here on the right hand side with
the mouse pad um the only real con I had
besides the fact that it takes G 2 USB
plugs is the fact that it has very soft
travel I would be typing I was actually
typing one of my essays with this and it
was just really really soft and that my
typing was slowed down a bit by using
this keyboard so you know that's true
the travel of it wasn't all that high
you do have to break in the keyboard it
does take a few days or a few a few
papers we're heading for language arts
to break in but you do actually just
have to break in this keyboard one
interesting thing that I'm still
experimenting with is this key down here
it actually has like a little land a key
I'm not sure but that's also the Windows
Start key so not a big deal that's
basically it for this keyboard review it
is a very simple very very well thought
out and well-built keyboard biotypes if
you want to check it out that link is in
the description you can obviously see if
you want to purchase this for yourself
there is a version for the Mac and for
the PC and this will make a great
addition to your desktop or to your desk
so thanks for watching this hardware
review video of the mattias USB 2.0
keyboard and if you haven't already
subscribed you might want to do so a lot
more hardware and software videos to
come and like I said earlier and like it
is written on my channel my 1000
subscriber giveaway is coming very
soon so you don't want to miss that guys
thanks for watching this hardware video
and thanks for subscribing peace